the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 video today I want
to discuss what is easily one of the
biggest theories in the game of thrones
ain't a Song of Ice and Fire community
the theory I am referring to is of
course who is a Zora hi now for those of
you who have been a subscriber of mine
for a long time already know this is a
theory I have discussed in many videos
already in fact I think almost every
game of Thrones youtuber has made
several videos on this theory alone the
reason why I decided to talk about this
again is because I recently saw an
article online that wanted to answer the
same thing now as you all know there was
a lot of controversy surrounding this
theory because Game of Thrones ended up
heading in a completely different
direction during their final season you
see most of us either assumed it would
be Jon Snow who killed the night king or
Daenerys Targaryen who would kill the
night King but the showrunners decided
to throw us a curveball by having Arya
Stark deliver that fatal blow this was
one of those big moments from the final
season that shattered the online fanbase
not only were millions of fans upset but
apparently so was kit harington the
actor who portrayed none other than Jon
Snow let's go ahead and see what he had
to say about that major event Kit
Harington was a bit pissed off he didn't
get to kill the Game of Thrones night
king it has been a few months since Game
of Thrones officially exited our lives
and getting over that breakup has been
pretty traumatic some fans were happy
with the way it all ended while others
petitioned that the final season be
redone entirely either way you got to
hand it to the show's biggest moments
like how the night king was eventually
felled if you're all caught up you
likely remember that it was none other
than Arya Stark Maisie Williams who
ended up taking the night King out for
good what's more brain stark Isaac
Hempstead right ended up as king if you
can believe that long story it likely
came as a shock that old Jon Snow Kit
Harington wasn't the one to plunge the
blade in the night king instead and for
fans a little annoyed that it didn't
happen well so his kid he said I was a
bit pissed off only be
I wanted to kill the night king he
divulged to The Hollywood Reporter about
Aria's night king eradication in the
series final season I think I felt like
everyone did and that it had been set up
for a long time and then I didn't get to
do it but I was so happy for amazed en
Arya I was secretly like I wanted to do
that Harrington said but it was really a
great twist and it tied up Macy's
journey in a really beautiful way over
the seasons we've seen her build up
these skills to become this hardened
assassin and she uses it all to kill our
main antagonist all's well that ends
well and you had to know our little
Orion needed an outlet for all that
pent-up rage what better than the
dastardly night king I think as we get
further and further away from the final
season we will start to see more actors
voice their opinion on how the show
ended we know damn well that at least
some of them were a little more than
just upset I did have a feeling that he
would be pissed off about not getting to
kill the night king we thought he did
deserve to get that kill because they
had built up his character to fight the
way Walker's ever since he joined the
Nights Watch in season 1 but imagine how
he had to feel considering he had to
work all those years setting up those
scenes to never get that big payoff with
his main adversary that would have been
very disappointing but let's continue
ever since that episode aired there have
been many articles written and videos
made detailing how Arya Stark was meant
to kill the night king the entire time
now I still happen to think the show
writers made that up on their own but
until george RR martin releases the next
book everyone is free to their own
opinion now I want to go over this
article because they believe they know
who is meant to be azor Ahai reborn in
George's books let's go ahead and see
what they had to say Jon Snow is azor
Ahai not Aria or Daenerys this scene
proves it Game of Thrones hero Jon Snow
is azor Ahai not Daenerys or even Arya
who killed the night king this scene
proves Melisandre is vision was right
after all the prince who is promised was
originally believed by readers to be Jon
Snow nobody was ever convinced by
Melisandre conviction it could be
Stannis Baratheon who would be
victorious in Game of Thrones but then
it was pointed out that the gender did
not have to mean a man suddenly Daenerys
became the prime suspect until of course
arias shocked the viewers by being the
one to dispatch the great evil which
threatened the entire world but actually
it is still John and always was the Lord
of Light showed Melisandre
but she did not understand her God
brought the stark in secret our carrion
backed the life for one clear reason the
books contain numerous prophecies and
mentions of this mythical prince who
will return at a time of greatest need
to turn back the darkness Daenerys has a
vision during a Clash of Kings in the
house of the undying she sees her
brother Rhaegar with his first wife Elia
Martell and their new baby son where
Rhaegar names his son Aegon and says he
has a song he as the prince that was
promised and his is the Song of Ice and
Fire there must be one more the dragon
has three heads
Rhaegar secret son John of course was
also named Aegon he is the only
character in the entire saga whose blood
combines Targaryen and Stark Fire and
Ice was Danny's vision purposefully
misleading to keep the truth from her in
the readers later in a dance with
dragons and increasingly confused
Melisandre searches for answers from her
god I prayed for a glimpse of azor Ahai
and where lore shows me only snow it is
easy to miss read this and think she is
only seeing snow which would still be a
big clue to Jon but the upper case
indicates that God is actually showing
her the man it is the Lord of Light who
gives his priestess the guidance and
power to bring John back from the dead
why what purpose does he still have
ultimately he doesn't defeat the night
King he doesn't even defeat Ramsay
Bolton to save the north and restore
Winterfell it did cause a huge fan
dismay when it was revealed on the HBO
final season that the night King had
rather been a red herring the threat
from beyond the wall was never the
central plot or the central danger
it seems that real or and presumably the
old gods of Westeros had one endgame in
John was the final tool to ensure it
came to pass the throne in the future of
Westeros were always intended for bran
Stark it seems the greatest danger
turned out to be Daenerys and it is not
just the increasingly horrified
Westerosi Lords who do not want her on
their throne it is the land itself john
was brought back to life and maneuvered
to the dragon queen side so he could
fulfill his destiny Danny's death even
incorporated the terrible part of the
prophecy which needed the prince who was
promised a plunge his blade into the
heart of his beloved to create the
mythical sword Lightbringer Martin's
books of course reveal in prophecies but
also make it clear the
should never be trusted however if
anyone is essaouira hi it is John okay
so as you can see they believe it's John
snow regardless of what may have
happened in the TV show like I have said
in my own videos I believe it to be John
snow as well in fact I have even used
the same evidence to support the theory
I do think malice Andres vision is a
good indicator of who is or 'hi really
is but I can also understand why some
would say that's not enough to convince
them now there are some other things
from the books that lead me to believe
it's John but I don't want to go through
all that right now all you would need to
do is watch my Melisandre is nice a nice
video to see what's direction I think
the books are heading in one of the
reasons why I wanted to discuss this
again is because I am curious to know
what some of you may think about this
now since the show has been off the air
for several months this has given us
some time to digest what happened in the
final season now that doesn't mean we
all accept that version but there's no
changing it so we're gonna have to live
with it until the books are released now
since we are discussing arias start
killing the night king there is
something else I want to read to you
because the director said something very
interesting about that scene now when I
say interesting what I really mean is
ridiculous but it's not his fault so
let's go ahead and take a look at it
Game of Thrones director shares why we
did not see how Arya was able to reach
the night king when Arya Stark killed
the night king in the long night many
Game of Thrones fans were shocked and
did not expect her to save Winterfell
now Game of Thrones director Miguel
suppose Sheikh is explaining why we did
not see how Arya Stark was able to reach
the night king before the big moment
Arya Starks kill scene during the long
night episode was a turning point for
the Game of Thrones plot when brain
stark in the night King are about to
confront each other
Arya Stark suddenly comes out of nowhere
and leaps toward the night king in the
end we felt it didn't matter how she got
there what mattered was setting up that
moment when the night King catches her
medley and we think she's done for then
she pulls out her knife switch and takes
him out so caution he told The Hollywood
Reporter in an interview I loved
Maisie's performance post the take down
as well sharing a moment with her
brother bran stark supports Nick
discussed why he scrapped the scene
where Arya Stark would be shown
traveling through the weirwood forest
since it would destroy the timing of the
night King's death I questioned
everything and we worked long and hard
to find the right balance of credibility
versus wish fulfillment then we shot it
and reshot it and found that was really
important
was rhythm support McCadden at one point
there was an elaborate plan to have her
fight her way into the weirwood force
but as we progressed we realized she'd
already done that earlier in the episode
so it felt like a repeat even though
Game of Thrones received mixed reviews
for its last season the series received
32 Emmy nominations including
Outstanding Drama Lead Actor in a Drama
and Lead Actress in a Drama now I guess
I should not be surprised because once
again the writers had thrown all the
logic out the window let me read that
sentence one more time they said in the
end we felt it did not matter how she
got there Wow
you know what I think I've had enough
for one day thanks for watching I really
appreciate that and I will see you all
again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you